et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
julien bayou bonjour connaître avec nos
secrétaire nationale d'europe écologie
les verts on est ensemble pendant 1
minute pour une interview en partenariat
avec la presse quotidienne régionale
représenté par fabrice veysseyre aux
dons du groupe ebra bonjour fabrice
riadh ben sur julien bayou conçu par
jour on va commencer avec la mort de ce
soldat français 53e soldat français de
l'opération barkan qui a été tué le
brigadier alexandre martin tués au mali
dans l' attaque du camp de l'opération
barca nagao est-ce qu'il faut maintenir
notre présent sur place julien bayou
déjà je leur adresser mes condoléances à
sa famille et puis le remercier ces
militaires qui s'engage pour
la paix et la sécurité dans le l'afrique
de l'ouest
là un départ aujourd'hui précipiter sous
le coup de l'émotion serait en fait
catastrophique ça serait vraiment cdac à
cette pression ça serait aussi abandonné
le mali qui est dans une période
transition aux mains d'un putschiste le
assimilé au heat a alors même que enfin
l'afrique de l'ouest la cedeao commence
à vouloir mettre des pressions pour
réengager à nouveau le mali sur la voie
de la transition donc c'est certainement
pas le bon moment pour partir à d'autant
plus forte raison qu'ils allaient les
miliciens de dour bague nerfs et avec
sont sous forte influence russe qui
commencent à placer leurs pions et donc
vraiment ce serait la pire des décisions
en revanche ce qu'il faut faire comme
manuel macro
opération en fait il faut partir le plus
vite possible évidemment la france a pas
rester ad vitam aeternam et même à
s'ingérer dans les affaires du mali ce
serait une forme de néocolonialisme
l'enjeu aujourd'hui mais d'ailleurs
yannick jadot l'allier encore tout
récemment c'est finalement de reprendre
le lien avec la cedeao avec l'union
africaine et même avec l'onu pour qu'en
fait aujourd'hui on soit en en situation
d'observation en capacité d'agir
éventuellement si
malheureusement la transition ne trouve
pas son chemin au mali
mais qu'on puisse travailler justement
excès ces organisations qui n'ont pas
forcément les forces de projection
suffisante nécessaire mais pour les
appuyer donc en lien avec la cedeao
l'union africaine et l'onu ce qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas le cas et donc moi
j'entends qu'emmanuel macro on va
organiser de nouveaux sommets dans le
cadre de la présidence française de
l'union européenne qu'il a voulu
explicitement calais pour resservir sa
campagne voyez ça c'est une forme
d'instrumentalisation de l'europe
l'enjeu est pas d'accueillir la cedeao à
bruxelles mais plutôt d'aller travailler
avec la cedeao avec l'union africaine à
la sortie de crise à la transition
démocratique au mali on va parler de la
crise sanitaire entrée en vigueur
aujourd'hui du pass vaccinale qui
remplace le pass sanitaire est ce pas
actionnaire qui a été validée par le
conseil constitutionnel à une exception
les meetings politiques est ce que vous
avez pensé de la décision du conseil
consiste à écouter moi je regrette en
fait qu'on transforme le pass sanitaire
qui pouvait fonctionner en impasse
vaccinale ou pour moi le vrai danger
c'est d'autoriser les cafetiers les
patrons de restaurants à vérifier votre
identité ça je crois que c'est vraiment
la source de
2,2 situation très problématique ça a
été validée même si c'est un problème
aujourd'hui vous savez on les juristes
musi alerte quand vous faites l'état
d'urgence il ya malheureusement
des situations qui perdure et qui sont
transcrites dans l'état de droit
notamment le l'absence de recours au
juge et avec l'état d'urgence sanitaire
la crainte c'est qu'également on laisse
aux générations futures un système où
l'état de droit a été bousculé et où des
mesures exorbitant du droit commun sont
pérennisés donc je le redis on ne peut
pas déléguer au privé les vérifier les
questions régalienne de contrôler
l'identité de sécurité à l'entrée d'un
restaurant
la personne qui va vérifier verra votre
prénom votre nom votre âge
qu'est ce qui détermine le contrôle un
doute voilà donc soit il personne va
vérifier et la loi et bavarder inutile
et c'est quand même un problème que la
loi soit à bavarder inutile soit cette
personne va s'autoriser à vous contrôler
mer sur la base de quel motif autre
couleur de peau oui c'est vraiment très
problème c'est que ça soit vous
comprenez que ça se transforme en
contrôle raciste
j'ai peur de j'ai peur de ce que ça peut
donner parce que quand c'est la police
quand c'est la gendarmerie nous avons
des voies de recours insuffisante mais
il ya des voies de recours là que voulez
vous faire vous voyez ça autorise des
situations potentiellement très très
problématique et qui peuvent se
pérenniser dans le temps voilà c'est moi
c'est ça mon a rejeté c'est le seul
point sur lequel vous émettez des
réserves le premier point je suis venu
là dessus mais le premier point c'est
que les autorités scientifiques ne le
recommande pas un nous écologistes nous
écoutons la science pour le climat il
faut agir emmanuel macron ne le fait pas
comme pour la pandémie est ni
l'organisation mondiale de la santé nih
le conseil scientifique ne recommande
cette contrainte finalement à la
vaccination l'enjeu c'est convaincre
plutôt que contraindre
en vigueur est ce qu'on peut encore
convaincre bel et bien sûr évidemment ça
continue évidemment et c'est
certainement pas via la contrainte que
vous allez convaincre la contrainte
aurait été d'imposer la vaccination mais
là c'est une vaccination obligatoire qui
ne dit pas son nom le président macron
l'a assumé de vouloir l' emmerder les
françaises et les français pourquoi at
il dit ça il a dit ça parce que la
veille la veille il avait perdu sa
majorité il avait perdu sa majorité
justement sur le pass
vaccinale qu'est ce que ça dit de vous
quand vous perdez votre majorité à trois
mois de l'échéance majeure de la
présidentielle il a finalement de
députés pour voter la prolongation de la
séance à la sq il était tombé morizet à
l'assemblée il a perdu il a voulu faire
une énorme diversion il avoue lui aussi
ciblé
désignés comme boucs émissaires les non
vaccinés moi je le redis les non
vaccinés
pour certains et pour certaines sont
éloignés des services publics est donc
un qui politise le sujet pour willy
l'instrumentalise bien sûr mais il est
il est en campagne il est en campagne ça
se voit ces différentes interventions
devraient être décompté de ce temps de
campagne et y compris mis à son compte
de campagne que pensez-vous du lord
lâchement annoncé déjà du desserrement
des vannes à dire que je ne comprends
pas là du coup je ne comprends pas le
jour même or entre ce qui ressemble à
une contrainte le pass vaccinale on vous
annonce un relâchement
à l'approché de la présidentielle on
avait vécu un petit peu déjà dix ans que
c'est grâce à l'entrée en vigueur de ce
pass actional qu'on peut relâcher s'est
passé c'est gonflé je pense que de
l'avis des commentateurs généraux enfin
de tout le monde c'est quand même gonflé
voilà en fait on a une
improvisation complète on l'a vu avec
blanc caire le miz l'éducation sur
l'école trois protocoles en une semaine
et une forme d'instrumentalisation
disons le évidemment parce que le pass
vaccinale pour montrer qu'on est dur
tout en envoyant des signaux de
relâchement non on doit pas relâcher
l'effort et l'enjeu c'est le soutenir à
nouveau les services publics l'éducation
comme l'hôpital et puis il ya une
hypocrisie majeur et peut-être moi je
vais prendre 30 secondes là dessus la
vaccination c'est bien c'est ça doit
devenir un bien public mondial et la
france je vous double jeu elle dit oui à
la libération des brevets mais elle agit
contre au niveau européen il n'y a pas
de stratégie vaccinale qui tiennent
passe vaccinale ou non il n'y a pas de
stratégie vaccinale autonome dans un
seul pays qui tient si vous laissez des
poches de populations mal vaccinés ou
peu vaccinés en afrique du sud ou aux
manies des populations pauvres
immunodéprimés ou peuvent se développer
des variants qui de toutes manières
reviendront en boomerang il a fallu
seulement un mois à omicron entre le
moment où il a été détecté et le moment
où des centaines de milliers de
françaises et de français ont été
frappés au monde notamment des fêtes de
noël donc ya pas de stratégie vaccinale
qui tienne la route en france si on ne
libère pas les brevets pour l'ensemble
de l'humanité c'est
une métaphore du climat il ya une menace
commune à l'ensemble de l'humanité et ne
nous devons tous et toutes agir et bien
c'est pareil sur la santé face à une
pandémie
il ya un lien entre la santé des êtres
humains et même en fait entre la santé
des écosystèmes là notre santé un
dernier mot sur ce sujet julien bayou
puisqu'il ya une nouvelle agression d'un
député de la majorité présidentielle
c'était ce week-end à perpignan par des
militants anti passé ce que vous êtes
inquiet de la tournure que prend ce
débat oui oui je vais pas je n'avais pas
entendu parler de cette cette agression
je sais que un précédent députés
à saint pierre et miquelon à saint
pierre et miquelon merci avait été
avaient été agressées également j'avais
apporter tout mon soutien oui il ya un
il ya
ces violences à l'égard des élus sont
absolument inacceptables tout simplement
voilà dans une démocratie on débat on
peut être rigoureusement désaccord le
dire de manière extrêmement frontale
mais absolument sans violence oui
excusez moi sur la question du vaccin et
un dernier mot on a bien compris vous
est ouvert au dialogue à la force de
conviction mais mais pas à la
vaccination obligatoire qu'est ce que
vous dites aux gens aujourd'hui qu'ils
ne veulent pas se faire vacciner
vaccinez vous allez voir votre médecin
lisez écoutez des médias reconnus on
sait qu'il ya énormément de fake news
qui circulent et des chiffres
extrêmement alarmistes qui repose sur
rien ou qui sont mal éclairées par des
personnes malintentionnées
je pourrais développer longuement mais
c'est pas mon rôle à moi de débusquer
des c'est que nous et je préfère que
vous médias reconnus et d'autre le
fassiez et puis un enjeu donc de d
instrumentaliser cette affaire quand
c'était manuel macron qui dit vaccinez
vous finalement sur une forme de
contrainte il se fait le plus mauvais
ambassadeur de la vaccination les bons
ambassadeurs les bonnes tomates cerises
de la vaccination c'est vous et moi qui
pouvons aborder les choses de manière
plus sereine sur les infirmières les
médecins qui peuvent ainsi convaincre je
pense à des personnes âgées qui sont pas
vaccinés qui sont les plus les plus
vulnérables les personnes obèses qui
peuvent avoir une inquiétude à l'égard
du vaccin voyez c'est pas d'autorité un
argument d'autorité qui peut emporter la
conviction intime c'est bien des
infirmes et des infirmières les
personnes les proches aux contacts qui
peuvent amener à faire ce choix pour soi
et pour les autres on va parler d'un
autre sujet julien bayou c'est la hausse
des prix qui inquiète évidemment les
français on va parler de la hausse des
prix de l'énergie mais d'abord la hausse
des prix dans l'alimentaire puisque le
prix des fruits et légumes par exemple a
augmenté de 9% entre 2019 et 2021
comment vous y répondez à ça mais déjà
il faut savoir d'où ça vient l'année
dernière vous alentours de février mars
on a eu un épisode de gel catastrophique
qui n'était pas absolument inédit mais
il venait après les périodes de très
forte chaleur
elle aboutit elle pour le coup était
inédite pour un mois de février et ça ça
endommagée on va dire les récoltes ce
qui fait qu'en juillet août vous avez eu
des prix conflent b et ça ne vient pas
de nulle part c'est lié très directement
liés au dérèglement climatique et à
l'inaction des pouvoirs publics qui
disent oh là là là le climat mais qui ne
font rien blablabla
c'est à dire que le dérèglement
climatique ça n'est pas un degré et demi
ou deux de manière très abstraite un cd
inondations des sécheresses un
renchérissement des fruits et légumes
des difficultés d'accès à l'eau potable
voilà du très concret la réponse
immédiate que nous proposons avec
yannick jadot c'est la tva à zéro pour
cent sur les produits bio locaux ceux
qui nous font du bien la réponse
immédiate c'est un chèque de 150 euros
ça s'appelle la sécurité sociale
alimentaire pour chaque ménage
la garantie de pouvoir se procurer
fruits et légumes alimentation de
qualité bio local chez dia en circuit
court directement chez les producteurs
c'est un moyen de soutenir très
concrètement et l'agriculture et
l'alimentation
là on sait qu' il ya des enfants qui
mangent pas à leur faim c'est d'autant
plus nécessaire d'avoir des cantines bio
parce que c'est le vrai bon repas par
jour quand on a fermé les cantines à
cause du du confinement je me souviens
que tout le monde s'était jeté sur
grégory douce et maire de lyon qui
voulait absolument maintenir les
cantines l'ouverte parce qu'il ya les 29
mille enfants qui en dépendaient eh bien
on sait que pour beaucoup d'enfants
c'est le vrai bon repas par jour sinon
c'est des chips au mieux vous voyez est
donc ça mène à obésité et pour le
problème de santé donc l'alimentation
doit être accessible à plus long terme
c'est évidemment la réorientation de la
politique agricole commune pour soutenir
l'alimentation de qualité bio les
revenus des des paysannes et paysans
mais c'est vraiment la manière de
répondre permettre à chacun et chacune
de se nourrir correctement les enseignes
edouard leclerc se battre distel pour un
pain moins cher des côtes de porc moins
cher
vous soutenez leur initiative non
malheureusement c'est populiste
peut-être populaire mais en fait ça se
traduit par une pression à la baisse
pour les producteurs et les productrices
en fait c'est comme pour le lait pour
tous ces produits sont des produits
d'appel qui permettent à ces grands
magasins dont je veux pas faire la pub
en fait de vous vendre un truc moins
cher mais pour tout le reste il se
rattrape sur les marges sur les produits
annexes et pendant ce temps là
évidemment les premiers producteurs les
premiers concernés sont pris à la gorge
on sait qu'il ya nombre d'agriculteurs
qui sont endettés au delà du raisonnable
qui ont du mal à se payer même un smic
ou même beaucoup moins et qu'ils en
finissent par le suicide donc nous il ya
un an j'ai eu de soutenir directement
l'agriculteur les agriculteurs et des
agricultrices
ça passe par la transition vers le la
bio je déplore qu'ils emmanuel macron là
encore double discours 10 nous
souhaitons la bio mais en fait il a
sabré dans les aides au maintien voire y
avait deux aides l'aide à la transition
et la double maintien on a besoin des
deux on a besoin d'augmenter les deux et
lui il à supprimer l'aide au maintien là
encore discours ambitions de façade et
double discours vis-à-vis de la hausse
des prix du carburant qui l'a aussi
inquiète julien bayou bruno le maire qui
était à votre place vendredi nous disait
travailler à de nouvelles mesures qu'est
ce que vous attendez du gouvernement et
ce qu'il faut de nouvelles aides pour
les français en fait on a un double
enjeu c'est que les dépenses on appelle
contraintes celles auxquelles pouvaient
pas échapper augmente donc c'est
l'alimentation c'est le carburant c'est
l'énergie l'électricité en particulier
on nous avait dit que le nucléaire ce
n'est pas cher mais on voit bien que en
fait ça n'est pas le cas c'est le loyer
c'est les assurances c'est les agios des
banques voyez les dépenses auxquelles
vous ne pouvez pas faire face et qui
empêche votre pouvoir de vivre c'est
moins de santé - de loisirs bon voilà
moins de moins de temps pour vous et
pendant ce temps là les revenus et
salaires en particulier ont pas augmenté
il ya eu des profiteurs de la crise
qu'ont fait qu'augmenter leur leur
patrimoine en centaines de milliards
c'était le rapport d'oxfam mais pour
pour les salariés lambda on va dire
smic 1,2 smic 2 smic tout ça rien a
augmenté et on n'est même pas non plus
pour les fonctionnaires le point
d'indicé est gelé depuis trop longtemps
donc nous les écologistes on va agir sur
les deux les deux axes réduire les
dépenses contraintes donc encadrement
des loyers la sécurité sociale
alimentaire un chèque de 150 euros pour
pouvoir nous nourrir
la tarification sociale les premiers
kilowattheures gratuit puis ça soit plus
cher en ce 8 mai comment on puisse
sécuriser le fait de voir ce que je fais
correctement la rénovation thermique
quand on rénove votre logement sans
reste à charge sans avances et ben ça
vous permet d'économiser sur la facture
si vous avez la malchance d'avoir un
convecteur électrique vous avez des
factures qui explosent en hiver et bien
que votre facture elle passe de 150 à 50
ça fait un treizième mois écolo c'est
comme ça qu'on l'appelle je pourrais
développer sur ces réductions des
dépenses contraintes encadrer des achats
de banques à augmenter les salaires
augmenter les salaires on en a besoin
aujourd'hui qu'on nous parle de valeur
travail
toutes les toutes les personnes qui
parlent de leur travail sont les
derniers à vouloir que le travail paye
dans ce pays nous voulons que le travail
paye dans ce pays ça veut dire augmenter
le smic augmenté les salaires juste
au-dessus aidés geler le point d'indicé
on va parler de la présidentielle est
d'abord un mot ça c'était la présence et
yannick jadot on va par un petit peu
politique sur ce qu'a dit eric zemmour
ce week-end il était en meeting à cannes
et il dit que s'il est élu il veut
introduire la notion de défense
excusable c'est à dire que un commerçant
qui est attaqué en policier qui est
attaqué pour riposter qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ça ce mec est fou dangereux ce
mec est fou dangereux soit il vous fait
peur soit ils le pensent face à
l'indigence soigne le pense parce qu'il
dit et c'est très dangereux soit y pense
ce qu'il dit et c'est très dangereux
voilà oui je pense que ce type de
proposition et dangereuse pour notre
société assure il a été et d'ailleurs
c'est un récidiviste de l'appel à la
haine des condamnations pour
pour pour racisme et autres c'est une
proposition absolument dangereuse je
vais pas passer beaucoup plus de temps à
développer la suge les dix délégués la
force de sécurité la violence légitime
comme on dit en droit au privé même sous
couvert de bonnes intentions c'est
extrêmement dangereux et les états unis
qui on sait ce malheureux chemin depuis
depuis de longues années en reviennent
parce que ça conduit à des drames
humains inqualifiable on va parler de 6
et certainement pas à plus de sécurité
certainement pas plus de sécurité ce qui
se passe chez les écologistes et à
gauche dans un entretien au journal
libération ce week-end christiane
taubira se définit comme une candidate
écologiste a dit qu'elle travaille
depuis longtemps sur le sujet c'est une
candidate écolo les symptômes et rend
alors dans ce cas là à l'humilité ne pas
en faire trop je n'ai pas entendu voilà
mais j'ai immensément de respect je
l'avais eue on s'est souhaité les voeux
on a parlé longuement
yannick jadot lui a proposé la tête de
liste aux européennes vous nous
confirmer ça non je jeu des membres
évidemment je démens évidemment j'étais
bien sûr très impliquée dans la campagne
des européennes
que dans les pulls l'a sollicité pour
soutenir la liste évidemment mais non
parce que tout simplement vous savez
chez nous c'est pas très compliqué on
vote et donc nous étions en plein vote
et c'est yannick jadot qui l'a emporté
pour conduire la liste des européennes
et je n'avais pas souvenir que
christiane taubira et et postulez donc
oui j'ai pas envie la contredire encore
une fois j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
elle simplement sur l'écologie sur les
points saillants les points principaux
pour nous c'est à dire nous sommes la
candidature l'écologie la justice
sociale la lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique et la lutte contre les
inégalités je ne vais pas beaucoup
entendu elle est notamment de guyane à
cayenne où la question de la
biodiversité absolument crucial en
france aussi métropole mais là vous avez
en en guyane des trésors de biodiversité
a absolument protéger et les problèmes
environnementaux se traduisent très très
directement par des questions de santé
en métropole aussi un là le lien entre
la pollution qui touche plus
particulièrement les quartiers
populaires est avérée mais en guyane
c'est encore pire les questions d'accès
l'eau potable les questions
d'empoisonnement au mercure sont légion
et son trait directement liée à leur
passage illégal ou légales et notamment
les questions de mines d'or à la
montagne d'or et je ne les ai jamais
entendu là-dessus en panne quand ici à
l'occasion de sa campagne elle prend
enfin position sur la montagne d'or je
m'en réjouirai si à l'occasion de sa
campagne altran enfin position sur la
centrales à fuel à côté de cayenne je
m'en réjouirai sur les explorateurs
exploration de la guyane ça sera une
très bonne nouvelle et peut-être au-delà
sur les sargasses un seriez en mesure de
travailler avec évidemment bien sûr nous
sommes en mesure de travailler avec
toutes les personnes qui souhaitent
soutenir la candidature de yannick jadot
la candidature de l'écologie et la
justice sociale la question risque de se
poser assez rapidement avec une primaire
populaire qui s'annonce là cette semaine
avec du talent soit annuler 30 il est
fort possible qu'elle soit en tête
ça peut changer quelque chose pour vous
tout ça à pas grand chose non nous on a
quatre cent soixante sept mille inscrits
à cette primaire populaire c'est
beaucoup plus sérieux j'ai appris cela
une investiture finalement
bain pendant c'est plus une primaire ses
investitures c'est une sorte de sondage
là dessus c'est très simple pour ce que
ça va donner une légitimité au candidat
par rapport aux autres un élan une
utilité n'est pas selon vous il ya
aujourd'hui une sorte de
fragmentation dire comme ça même
l'extrême droite et divise vous avez
deux candidatures d'extrêmement et vous
avez deux candidatures de droite moi je
mets a très très peu de de distinguo
entre valérie pécresse et emmanuel
macron et d'ailleurs ils ont une énorme
pour aux hits et de leur électorat il ya
une foule de candidatures à gauche toute
n'iront pas au bout à on verra
ça les regarde ça les regarde moi je
fais
ça ne fait finalement ça ne me concerne
qu'assez peu parce que là où je veux en
venir c'est qui a qu'une seule
candidature de l'écologie et la justice
sociale vous avez les réactionnaires les
conservateurs et les progressistes et
bien le progressisme du 21e siècle c'est
l'écologie et la justice sociale c'est
la candidature de yannick jadot donc
j'ai bien vu qu'à gauche certains
certaines avaient des difficultés pour
se départager notamment les socialistes
qui ont pu soutenir le mandat hollande
et valls ça n'est pas mon projet dont
qu'ils arbitrent entre eux entre elles
qui doit continuer ou qui je ne sais pas
quoi
entre crescent opéra et anne hidalgo
pour vous il y en a une qui doit qui
doit laisser la place je ne suis pas
concerné
un dernier mot sur ce qui se passe à
grenoble d'être avec vous fabrice mais
avec une fracture dans la majorité des
rich iott sur la question du burkina à
berck nom avant longtemps qu'on n'en
parlait pas appuyé en plus en janvier
évidemment b de saison c'est de saison
voilà ce qui s'est passé à grenoble dans
la majorité municipale à grenoble qui
s'imposent fracturé sur cette question
c'était la semaine dernière avec une
démission d'une conseillère municipale
eric piolle puisqu'il ya il a refusé de
trancher à l'issue d'une médiation avec
une association qui organisait des
opérations burqini dans les piscines
c'est un sujet qu'il gêne encore dans un
parti non pas tellement en fait la
position du défenseur des droits est
très clair le burqini est légal les
règlements intérieurs de certaines
piscines l'interdisent et donc eric
piolle maire de grenoble à bon droit dit
à écouter c'est un service public les
usagères
sont libres sont pas concernés par les
questions de laïcité 1 le burqini même
si peut-être c'était le sens de votre
question n'est pas une question de
laïcité selon les défenseurs des droits
qui se sont succédé sur la question
c'est une question éventuellement
d'hygiène et sécurité un homme avec un
bermuda qui se balade dans la rue avec
ne peut pas rentrer dans la piscine
parce que ça fait amener des microbes et
c'est donc ça on peut l'entendre c'est
pour ça peut-être que certains
règlements l'interdisent et donc eric
piolle de manière pragmatique dit à
écouter en fait ça serait compliqué
c'est que certains règlements intérieurs
l'autorisent et d'autres non et demande
au premier ministre de trancher le faire
passer la circulaire le l'arrêté qui
convient pour harmoniser la position
entre les différentes villes je regrette
que castex et macron tout à la
préparation de la campagne du candidat
n'ait pas pris le temps n'ait pas cru
bon de répondre si cette question et si
brûlante j'aurais imaginé que le
gouvernement se serait pas se précipiter
dessus pour y répondre mais en fait en
vrai je pense pas que ce soit l'enjeu
majeur de ces temps ci merci merci
ce matin
[Musique]